COMMITTEE FOR MONEY EFFORT OR
TWENTY SIX IS HEREBY COULD
BEING.
GROWS CHO IS CALLED ORDER.
FUTURE BISON AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S. HEARING IS
BEING MADE. AND IS ALSO IN
TELEVISED THAT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HERE.
ALLEN.
PEROT
CARILLO
CERVANTES.
FRIEDMAN
GRAYSON.
THOSE.
LET'S AREA PRESENT.
SOLACE WALDRON FEAR PROBLEM
HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA. IS OUR MOST ON
THE COUSIN AGENDA.
WHO MEMBERS TO FONG SECONDED BY
MISTER GRAYSON?
BAD CENTERPIECE CULTURAL COOLEY.
AYE COOLEY AYE ALLEN THOROUGH.
MARIA.
CARILLO EYES ARE BONTA.
BECAUSE I FRIEDMAN GRAYSON AYE
GRAYSON AYE NOSE AREA. FIGHT
CLOSER AND I SAW LIST WALDRON.
OVER AN IPHONE.
PHONE I.
THE MOTION IS PASSED AND NTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH